official Unity Day celebrations began
with the church service in Hanover
alongside the Christians Jewish and
Islamic religious leaders took part the
sign Derman II has become a
multicultural and multi-faith nation
then at the official Unity Day ceremony
around 1,000 guests watched an
emotionally charged stage show that told
the story of German unification over the
years German Chancellor Angela Merkel
said East and West wouldn't have come
together without the courage of East
Germans who protested for democracy
before the wall came down she also said
there was no longer a clear economic
divide between the former East and West
these days there are economically
attractive regions all over the country
there are university towns that attract
more and more people and there are also
regions all over the country that lack
infrastructure that have struggling
economies debt and demographic problems
Merkel also spoke about challenges
facing Germany and the international
community
she said the spirit of unity was what
led it to join the fight against Islamic
state it might be tempting not to even
begin the struggle against these
terrorists to hope that the problem
might just solve itself but it won't
it's a challenge for the whole world not
just for the United States and not just
for the Arab world
no it involves all of us who believe in
the phrase human dignity is inviolable
that's that's the rule that does mention
artists but is it fast Bedoya today that
line from the german constitution sums
up the goals that the nation strives for
within itself and also in the wider
world
you